okay it's that time again
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
your absolutely
favorite podcast
[Music]
this is
all right charlie huh just the girls
[Music]
welcome back
[Music]
[Music]
everywhere
yeah that's how we do it
that's how we do it we reef we're
griffin
within i know y'all love the intro i
love the intro too shout out once again
to
uh detective design dopapod and uh i
forgot the other name
i've been i haven't shout them out in a
while but yeah they made that dope song
i'm still getting some good music from
people so i really appreciate
that so welcome back to riffing with
griffin
um damn it's uh
we're still going huh
episode 119 or 120 i'm not even sure
what episode this is i don't even know
i'm just such a homebody man i don't
know this world is crazy
for me like i just i realize how much i
like to just stay at home i'm just
always at home
um so i don't know i went out and i did
king and the sting
this past week with theo and brendan so
that was fun
got a lot of love for that people hit me
up and people are coming to my gaming
channel because of king and sting so
if you still want to watch me game or if
you've never seen me game you don't know
what i'm talking about i'm on twitch
every single day
twitch dot tv slash eric griffin gaming
so come check out eric griffin gaming
i do have a patreon even though i just i
i don't do enough on it
so you're just going there to just
support me but there's so many ways to
support me too there's so many links
you know paypal if you want to just tip
the show or even on twitch there's so
many different ways to like support
that kind of thing so i'm trying to
convince rachel to do more videos that
we could put up on patreon
and then but she she really gets
meticulous about it so and she wants to
start her own thing she wants to stand
on so i'm gonna have rachel on today
and her and i could do some talking um
but you know
first just here i am eric griffin so
like i said i did king of this thing and
that was fun we had a fun conversation
you know it's like sometimes i don't
know like i get on my podcast and i come
by myself and i just get so serious or
i don't know it's just a different tone
right it's a different tone different
different type of podcast as opposed to
when
you when i have a guest or when i have
or when i'm on other people's podcasts
because i guess you go on other people's
podcast and you get into like a guest
mode where you get into like i just
turned into like
funny grumpy guy or whatever it is like
that i i can't even explain it so i mean
i'd love to hear your comments you know
and
you know the good ones not meaning good
comments but constructive comments
they can be good or they could even be
like well i don't like this because of
this as long as you like you know
express yourself be honest i don't mind
a good
i don't mind a good uh a good good
comment i mean because comments can get
so weird like
i somebody somebody tweeted uh no i saw
this article about some it was an older
senator
some older senator he got the vaccine
and then
he tested positive for covet so i i
retweeted that article and all i said
was welp
you know because it really was a whop
like what like
like not it's just kind of those things
it was kind of like a damn
like damned if you do damned if you
don't or it's it's no political
statement no nothing about it
and then you i just got like so many
people just hit me up with like you live
in a box
you don't you know you're stupid and i'm
just like damn you got all that from
welp and so
you know it's like i realized like
people could people are going to think
whatever they want to think
and sometimes just your tweets as
somebody that's a pseudo celebrity just
inspires people to get out all their
their
whatever that is it's weird i mean i
guess it's different i guess
we've always felt like this if you think
about it like you probably
we've probably always had in the back of
our heads like
like you might hear a critic a long time
ago say something and
you know you're at home going oh this
guy's an idiot and then like social
media has allowed us to like
say that publicly to you know more
people than we normally would
because even if you don't have a lot of
followers let's say you got
60 people following you and for social
media that's not a lot of people right
60 people
but if you think about it when are you
ever in front of 60 people that you
could just be like
this dude ain't [ __ ] you know so
so it's like even someone like that it
gives people a voice
that they probably have always had but
just never had a chance to
never had a chance to say anything i
mean if you think about it um
[Music]
like if you're a fan of justin bieber of
someone like that of such a high pop
star level 100 million followers
you know of those 100 million followers
you could be somebody that just
you could be like oh justin i love you
and and then
you know he could just be at home going
let me see what the fans are saying
today
let me go check my dms just to let you
know for someone like that it's probably
you know it's probably ridiculous i
remember the one time he like
tagged me in a photo when he came to the
laugh factory and he tagged me in a
photo
i'm talking about for a month my phone
was buzzing like if i had the
notifications on it was just business
i was like oh my god people like that
probably never had their notifications
on
but all i'm trying to say is that you
possibly could
say hi to him and he could be like oh
okay here's one fan i want to say hi to
like there's more opportunity to
actually
say hello to
a person that you're a super fan of i
mean for me i
like i listen to audiobooks and i love
finding out who the performer is on the
audiobook
and i'll find that person's twitter and
be like yo love your work i read such
and such book and you really made it you
know
sometimes someone like that they love
hearing that they're like oh man you
made my day thanks for
you know so i mean it's like it's not
all bad i'm not going to sit here being
like some old curmudgeon
who's like oh social media is terrible
and all this kind of stuff i mean you
know it is it's just how people use it
just like any weapon
you know anything could be weaponized is
what i'm trying to say
anything could be weaponized that has
the best of intentions can be weaponized
so
yeah i love saying hello to like people
like that you know
an author you know what i mean it's like
you send some somebody some love
like if you like anything you know it
could be literally anything it could be
a product that you use and you found out
that
it was such a such scientist and made it
you'd be surprised you find them on
twitter and or
instagram would be like yo man love this
thing you made and then
they might be like oh wow thank you and
it's like how amazing is it that we're
so
able to touch someone that is so like
not even in our circle at all but we
have this like connection
through social media so
i do like that so i'm i'm just trying to
figure out like you know i
it's like i've been on rick glass like
when i go on rick's
glassman's podcast and i go on like say
jeremiah watkins podcast
i have this thing about myself where
like you know i i get like i'm like the
old grandpa guy and i'm like god this is
stupid but i still do whatever they say
but
you know sometimes i feel like oh i'm
just doing that to be funny is that part
of my personality but then after a while
i start to go damn i don't know if i
like this
it's like am i like the old am i like to
curmudgeon all the time is that funny is
that my brand
it's like it's like somebody tweeted
somebody wrote on a
king in the stings thing like they saw i
was on the pod
i was gonna be on the um the podcast and
the guy says on instagram
i'll pass eric griffin is a whiny [ __ ]
you know and i was like well damn
another guy said another guy said uh
oh man every podcast you complain on
every podcast
you know something some kind of thing
and i go and i started to think about it
like what are you talking about right
then i thought well that is part of my
brand actually
like i complain because it's funny to
complain like i talk about things
like that annoy me you know i'm not
complaining
it's not always a complaint it's more
just like i'm pointing out
you know what i can't stand because i
think that's funny that's part of like
what i do in my comedy
but it's it's you know when i see it
written like that when somebody says you
complain too much
that's the thing bobby lee says all the
time bobby's always like are you
complaining too much even though
he's complaining about me complaining so
you're complaining i'm a [ __ ]
he complains all the time on his part
all he does is complain but like for
some reason he said that to me now
everybody thinks yeah
that guy complains and they just like
you know write me this message all the
time you complain you know i don't know
maybe i do complain so i'm just starting
to embrace it i'm gonna embrace it
but then i'm also gonna be aware of it
you know i saw
on um tiger belly i didn't watch i don't
watch tiger belly all the time i don't
watch any podcast and it's nothing
against them anyway i just i don't like
watching podcasts it's hard i'm not even
though you guys are watching podcast
the reason for me is that i don't want
too many other people's thoughts in my
head as i'm doing my own thing
because i'm sure there's a lot of
overlap we're all talking about the same
things especially something like covid
or something like that
but anyways i saw on bobby's instagram
and talking about instagram he was like
you know he says the original
instead of bad friends they were going
to call it riffin without griffin
[Laughter]
and i thought i thought that was funny i
thought it was like really funny but
then he goes on to say like he's saying
like
you know oh but if we would have called
it that it really would have hurt eric
and it would have been
irrep irreparable er whatever that word
is
you know terrible damage to our
relationship and i thought to myself
man they really overestimate
what i really think about them doing a
podcast
i i l i love both those guys
i talk to andrew all the time i actually
talk to andrew way more than i talk to
bobby
i have no problem with them doing a
podcast my problem was
always the way bobby handled it he
didn't handle it like a man
he didn't he told me we were going to do
he told me all this stuff
all these promises and then all of a
sudden he just didn't do it
and then he even called me like you know
that
it just that's what i have always had a
problem with you know
but i went on the podcast we him and i
have already talked about he talked it
out on my podcast
he apologized but this narrative is
still out there that i'm like
oh my god i can't no guys it was always
it was the fire burned because it was
funny
to the fans it was funny to you guys to
think that we had a beef so we just kept
it going
andrew and i talk about it all the time
we laugh about it because it's not
but now it's getting to the point where
it's like oh does bobby think that
does he think i care that much about
that kind of stuff
so i don't know so then that makes me
think about myself like damn have i put
out some sort of energy to my friends
that they think a certain way
because let me tell you something that
that is not the case
at all i wish them all the best i love
the success i love clowning them i love
talking smack about them
again i talk to andrew all the time he's
constantly you know
on my podcast i've gone on his i mean we
you know what i mean
like we it's like there is no beef
you know actually since i've done this i
haven't been back on tiger belly you
know what i mean
you know what i mean since you know if
there's anybody that has a problem it's
not me
you know what i mean so i don't know
what's going on there but i just want to
let you guys know that people that watch
both because there's a lot of tiger
belly fans here
i'm just letting you know like there's
no problem if they would have named it
that it would have been hilarious
i would have laughed and they would have
it would have been a so it would have
been funny the way i would have you know
reacted i would have done that thing
that i do and then
everybody be laughing but behind the
scenes we would have just been like you
know that would have been funny but they
never would have named that even if they
would have done it as a joke
i know that it would have been a joke
i'm not i'm not a crazy person you know
what i mean so
i don't know i just want to put that out
there it's like
what you know a lot of you watch bad
friends watch it you know you like they
have a great dynamic
in the same way that when andrew comes
on my podcast i get a lot more views i
get 10 times more views than i normally
get
when by myself uh same thing with bobby
when bobby comes on i get so many more
views you know so
i don't know i i just i you know it's
like people like us
together so you know it is what it is i
went on their podcast and then people
keep saying man you got to go back on
bad friends you know it's like every
podcast i go on people say that to me
all the time like oh man you were good
on that one they should have you back
more
so that's a compliment to me but it's
also a compliment to
you know the chemistry i have with the
people that are my friends that
we can go on and have such a good time
so i don't know
again i thought it was funny i really
have no issue
it's not an issue at all you know maybe
if they say dust protest too much i'm
not
i don't even know see you you're damned
if you do you damn [ __ ] i don't so no
matter what i say people are gonna say
whatever they say so
i'm just being as truthful and honest as
i can you guys
that watch my podcast all the time you
can kind of get a sense of the kind of
person i am or when i'm
saying something that's genuine from my
heart and you know that's really what i
what i feel about that so that's all i
want to say about that
so i i told you that i was going to
watch this denzel washington movie
uh the little things ramy malcolm that's
the guy's name i forgot from last week
so this is called little thing the
little things
so it's starring jared leto denzel
washington and rami malko it's on hbo
max it was one of those movies that was
supposed to go to theaters
so they're putting it right on hbo max
it's probably in theaters in the country
and
in the states that don't care that you
know they still have
indoor things so i want to do my review
of that movie
i thought it was a great movie i thought
it was really good it's a fantastic
movie
but part of it that makes it fantastic
is when you watch a movie like that how
they publicize it is like
oscar winner oscar winner oscar winner
so there's a part of you that's like
you already have a higher expectation
of what you're going to get in the movie
because everybody in the movie is an
oscar winner you know
but part sometimes i think that takes
away from it because then you're like
always
you're always like focused on that oh
these guys won the oscar let's see what
kind of
you know oh it's going to be a great
performance it has to be and then you
kind of feel like oh man are you guys
trying to win
oscars like you're you're you you can't
suspend your disbelief
within the characters because you're
still seeing
that haze of oh wow the
how did they get these three oscar
winners together and then you're just
you're
you know that's all you can see but once
you get past that now the movie's slow
it's a slow pacing show now spoiler
alert
and i don't even know if i'm going to
spoil anything but i did say last week
on the episode
that i thought the way they did the
trailer that denzel washington was the
killer
you know i thought that i thought like
oh this is going to be the twist
and it was just the nature of how they
put the trailer together now i want to
say this
in terms of the story of what's going on
in the movie
i was wrong but i was also right
i was also right so you have to i'm not
going to spoil it for you till next week
but i was right but anyway the movie
starts you know so
you know there's this you know
really creepy chase scene you know this
this girl's in a car and an and then
another and it's on like a
a white a dark highway road and
this car is like chasing her
you know and she's trying to get away
and then she does
some dumb scary movie white girl [ __ ]
okay she stops at
a clearly closed like
diner and gets out of her car
to go help help
[ __ ] you in a car like drive away
you know what i mean like that i almost
turned the movie off at that point
and i'm just telling you guys when you
watch don't turn it off at that point
because that is something that is hard
to get past
if you're a logical person and you watch
a lot of movies you're just like
why did this white girl get out the car
why does she get out the car
leave their keys in the car leave the
car running to go bang on a a a clearly
closed place looking for help
i i just i i like i said i almost turned
the movie off
but anyway and then you meet denzel
washington and now normally denzel
washington
in a movie i believe this dude
like there's something about him that
whatever character he's playing
you believe it but now that he's gotten
older it's like this kind of thing where
it's always like a sort of grisly
the x something or other or the old
school this or that and that's what he's
playing in this movie too he's like a
former
la detective they kind of say
something happened to him they kind of
hint at it and you don't find out to the
end of the movie what that is
i won't spoil it for you and then you
know he was actually a great detective
he was on like a murder case and but now
he's in kern county
he lives on like a little dirt path you
know house with a
with a dog that just comes by once a
week and you know his boss sends him on
a
uh evidence like go send
take this evidence go pick up some
evidence from la
so he goes to his old place of you know
where he worked and everybody knows him
you know he's kind of famous and then
like ramy malko is that the guy's name i
think it's his name the guy from mr
robot
he's now the new big shot detective and
he's on a serial killer case and he's
given a press conference and
denzel's washington is washing watching
him and
you know it's just whole like thing
where you know
it's you know it's very it reminds me of
seven a little bit okay
there's like some seven in there you
know if you liked seven with uh
brad pitt and uh morgan freeman was it
morgan freeman yeah morgan freeman
i love that movie seven is still i can
watch seven right now and enjoy every
single second of it okay
so seven it kind of had that feel of it
like
one guy's trying to retire he's got a
lot of experience and there's a new
hungry guy who's like on the case
so and then you know the whole movie is
slow and then you meet jared leto who is
like
in the movie he calls himself a crime
buff but he's clearly creepy you clearly
think
he did it he does things and says things
that you might think he did it but it's
kind of iffy
you know but he is creepy and he's smart
and he's like
you know you know it's just
they don't really say if he did it or
not you know what i mean like
you know i don't know again i don't want
to spoil anything for you too much
so you watch it and then something
happens
in the end that kind of ties what
happened to denzel washington
to something that the new guy does and
it's like you know
i don't know if it was worth it in the
end you know it was a long movie
um i do recommend it because there ain't
nothing else going on anyway
it is really great performances these
guys sort of get lost in the characters
but like i say i think it was like
you know too proud of itself you know in
terms of uh
because of who these guys are so i
definitely
i definitely like i said i recommend it
i soft recommend it
um it is good performances and then like
it's one of those at the end you go oh
you know and then i'll wait a couple
more weeks to like
really get into it maybe i'll put up a
post about it so we can like
you know we can all like talk smack
about it but like i say i
i highly recommend that so check that
out
so next week um you know next week is
the super bowl
um i kind of feel like
i'm gonna watch the super bowl and then
i'm gonna do my podcast
so i'll probably be talking about
the super bowl being like wow i can't
believe so and so one
i think there's a lot on the line for
more so for patrick mahomes than it is
for
tom brady i mean it is amazing that tom
brady at age 43
you know played every single game got
himself to this point
to me sort of solidifying for himself
like hey he is great
that it is beyond just athleticism that
makes him great
he's a leader of men he inspired this
team he was the one quarterback away
from making them a fantastic team along
with adding some crucial pieces
just because you have a superstar team
doesn't mean that superstar team is
going to win
it does take a certain personality and
sometimes one man can make the
difference and
it looks like that one man is tom brady
so kudos to him
and if he wins it just stamps it he
should retire
if tom brady wins he should just ride
off into the sunset like i'm the
greatest ever
[ __ ] buy you know because one right
now
what tom brady is doing right now is
probably his
greatest accomplishment for the rest of
his life
because he has this tb12 brand that is
about nutrition and health and exercise
and all this stuff
and he is the perfect spokesperson for
it because he's saying to everybody
hey mother hey [ __ ] i'm 43
and i'm playing the hardest position in
sports
and i'm still doing it at a high level
all because of tb12 like he'll be able
to talk about tb12 for the
rest of his life and probably make a
billion dollars
like look for tom brady to go into like
the business
after this everyone you know you just
want to be around that
you know if he wins it'll be seven
championships but even if he doesn't win
he's still gonna do this for his career
because he's gonna be like
man tb12 got me all the way to this
point you
you too later in your life will be able
to do such and such if you follow this i
mean
it is a road map for success the guy
works hard he's committed he's got a
beautiful wife he's got great kids
you know you know what i mean it's like
good job for tom brady so it's a win-win
for him regardless right
now on the other side here's patrick
mahomes
you know his first year as a starter
they get all the way to the afc
championship and they lose to a pre-snap
penalty
which they would have gone to the super
bowl against the rams and probably would
have beat them right
he wins the mvp that years those 50
touchdowns he
you know you know what i'm saying he
wins the mvp he throws 50 touchdowns he
gets the afc championship
next year his team wins the
super bowl he's super bowl mvp this year
they are
14-1 regular season
15-1 whatever they only lost one game in
a regular season they came back and beat
that team again
the raiders that beat them so they beat
every team on their schedule
now they're in the super bowl again in
his third year as a starter
i mean if he beats tom brady right now
you know we're gonna be like wow the
young guy the torch has been passed
here it is this guy's on on the road to
being the greatest ever
like take a quarterback that's had say a
10
year career you know quarterbacks that
have had a 10-year career
if they had an mvp a super bowl mvp
and two super bowl appearances and let's
say he wins
man that's a hall of fame career for
anyone else even if they played for 15
years and had mediocre
you're talking about like and the way
he's played like look at eli manning eli
manning is already a borderline
borderline hall of fame but he's got two
super bowls against tom brady right
but his other stats make it go uh i mean
patrick holmes
he's on the road to having great stats
great
accomplishments and here he is in only
his
third season as a starter like who knows
sky's the limit for that guy so i think
a lot is on the line for patrick mahomes
to win this championship
you know what i mean so who
we shall see
but anyways um that's just my solo
portion
of the podcast uh you know uh i'm
bringing rachel on
and she is her and i are going to yip
yap for
a little while so here she is
you don't need those if you don't want
them
[Music]
they want to make fuel you feel more
professional with them
i feel like you yeah but what does it do
to your hair does it matter i don't know
what it's doing
is it messing up your hair so you're
just gonna look at this mirror the whole
time
okay you're right the hair rachel but i
need you to
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're not on camera right now
you're messing no that's
what what what is that
like a jimmy neutron yeah i just i think
you should take the headphones off
because
it's just grease lightning yeah cause
there's something weird going on
it's like a poof yeah it's poofing
spread them apart there you go
i don't think as long as i hear your
voice good there you go
how's my hair now i think it looks great
okay
we'll start a poll how does her hair
look oh no
please don't
you did a video and they're like so you
like deleted comments
[Laughter]
i deleted it i think
one comment right really why
because it was just rude and
disrespectful no it was just about
um a
something that had nothing to do with my
video yeah i understand
but you know when you start getting like
more views and stuff like that i told
you
you just kind of ignore the comments
even i have trouble ignoring comments
because it's just sometimes you just go
why would you say that well you know i
never
really looked at them because i like
have the youtube app
on my phone but like you know i go on
there to just look how many
like views i had and like how many
subscribers i got
and then you're like oh you need to
download this app and this app
and so i'm like downloading all these
youtube like
apps and like when you open it
it's like as soon as you open it up it
has
all the comments
i know then your eye just goes through
you can't help it and then you go down
to rabbit hole you're just like
this person yeah it says like five new
comments and it's like are you gonna
click it or are you
gonna like close the app and it's like
sometimes it's just like okay let's just
see if they're positive or negative
and it's not that i even care but i just
don't want the attention to go
somewhere else yeah it is what it is i
totally get what you're saying
it's it's like some you know sometimes
sometimes it gets to you sometimes it
doesn't sometimes you can just brush it
off like ah or that person whatever then
other times you just go oh man ouch
like why say that it's like those
comment all those comments before you
know she's a gold digger and
you know it's like what you know you
don't even
i don't know just people people got a
lot of time on their hands
but i have then you find yourself having
to defend people you know
you defend yourself you know you finally
just like why would you that's not true
or whatever it is like that so i don't
know no it was
um someone like comparing me
to someone else and i just i didn't like
the person they were comparing me to
so i just deleted it
people get in trouble for that though
but i guess but you're i love your
attitude about it you're like i don't
care this is my thing i want all
positivity if there's no positivity
you're out so
just so you know
[Laughter]
when rachel starts our podcast i hate my
boyfriend's couch
is that the working title or what's the
other one that is the working title
um or
you know i haven't really gave it much
thought to be honest because i'm just
right now working on content rather than
title
are we going to talk about how your
friends came over and now they have
covet
you know i was thinking about that i'm
like should i mention that
you know what we don't got to mention
their names but you know yeah her our
our friends came over they're my friends
too now and then like
they had traveled you know and then
[Laughter]
i mean we we got this new place and none
of our friends have really
seen it so like you know i was kind of
excited to invite them over
and when i did
she opened mouth coughed
while we were eating like at the table
that we were eating at
and like accidentally like no one said
anything
i looked at eric but like he didn't
catch on i didn't get yeah you you
didn't want to cut that one
the whole time i was just like i can't
she is not my friend
if she's open to help coughing during
coven season
i know it's like even you sometimes will
go to the grocery store
and you'll just accidentally cough i got
my mask on
some okay this is what i hate though
here we go
you do here we go when you use
apple pay it is easier yes
but do not remove your mask in front of
other people
if you're alone sure no one's around me
i just take the mask out for a second
i license i do the part i do the apple
thing so they can
i do the password thing and then i boom
i don't want to type my password in
no it's it's 20 21 we don't do that
anymore
you get a quick password that you know
that you could just type in that you
don't remove your mask
until all masks are able to be removed
don't do that it's embarrassing
oh so you got to get on my podcast and
just call me out huh this is like you're
going to like you wanted to call my
friends out
i didn't call you you know what i didn't
i wasn't talking about
she opened mouth coughed i didn't say
all that stuff that was you
well but when you do call like it is we
are a little bit more sensitive
even even before cover somebody open
mouth cough you just go hey
yeah yeah like that's like i felt it on
my neck
you know or like you know when you're in
school and like you could feel the
breeze of someone sneeze or cough
oh i hate that and you're just like that
touched me and i feel
a little like sneezing is different
somebody sneeze on you that's different
like if you cause a sneeze
has wet particles okay but a sneeze
isn't part of the
like the covid protocol of like no if
somebody sneezes and they have covet
look if if somebody if some dust came
near somebody that has covete and they
sneezed and some wet stuff came on you
that's worse than a cough no but like
under like
symptoms of cold okay that's different
you're talking about the symptoms as
opposed to
i'm talking about what's nastier a
sneeze or a cough
you know what's funny right now i gotta
tell you what's happening with her right
now i know her so well
she does not want to tell me i'm right
like like her whole body language right
now is like
i agree sneezing is nastier than
coughing
but i don't want him to know that
they are it is like any wet particle
that gets on you
no let's talk about why you why can't
you just why can't you just agree with
me why you always gotta fight with
everything i say
i'm not trying to fight i just i like a
healthy argue
is that healthy a healthy media argue
oh man she then at the end you eat it a
little
i had her i had a note i wrote down
about
something about you then you started to
like this is what happens sometimes
we'll be out some place and i'll say
something and she said something back to
me and i go oh you know what we should
say that for the podcast and here's one
of these moments
you're so selfish with food oh man you
are so selfish for food
like if she has some food and i'll be
like oh let me have some of that
you look at me like i'm crazy okay you
don't understand
please please explain it to me that's
what i want you to explain to explain to
me why you're so damn selfish
with two brothers okay and
a hungry dad
so a hungry dad so
you know my mom would either cook dinner
and get us
food bring it home if you're not at that
table within like
five minutes of it being at home
or like being at you know able to eat
then it's gone
oh and it's my only child so i i don't
yeah i understand that
and so i think it's always just like
fight or flight when it comes to food
because if
you don't eat it then someone else is
going to and so if i want it i have to
protect it
yeah but here's the thing though
survival of the video i always know
you're not gonna finish it
well that's why at the end i'm okay with
you eating it
because i know i've had my fill you know
you know what she does too here's
something else that you like to do
i'll be like so the other night it's
late
and i was like you know what i want some
cereal i know she don't want cereal
she's full i know you full
because we had a big-ass dinner and you
didn't even eat all of that because i
know when you're full when we're
when rachel's falling craving of like
something sweet
like when you especially when you see
someone else eating something sweet
you're like oh i want a little bite but
then you get so defensive as well
and you're like i am not giving you a
bite this is my
cereal yeah and that's what i'm that's
when i'm gonna want it more i'm a
sibling
you have to share this is when
i like have the memories of like crying
to my mom and dad and be like
i didn't get any oh you were probably a
monster huh i think my
my family just like we were all monsters
no but you were particularly i'm gonna
get some i got to get some intel on the
on the family zoom you know we still do
the family zoom guys with her grandma
even though her brother who is a poet
now
[Laughter]
why are you laughing i don't understand
why that's so funny
when oh this is great rachel her
michael rachel's brother is her
favorite okay she loves her brother
where she will start crying about how
much she loves her brother you know what
i mean
and so right now you're so defending
your brother even though
when he is reading his poems okay like
you know if i was like a big poet fan i
would like be married
or like you know be engaged to someone
who
wrote poetry that would recite poems to
me i like to laugh so i'm with
a comedian i'm a poet you don't know it
well you are sometimes okay baby talking
to the mic
okay well i'm just saying that
it's a it's a
what's it called when you have like a
certain thing you're good at
like you're being very nice right now i
like this
first of all your brother don't even
listen to my podcast so you don't have
to worry about it
michael writes a lot of he this is his
thing now he
he well he got to a point in his life
that he doesn't have to have like a day
job
yeah and he actually trades stock he's
doing pretty good at it even though he
won't
even though he won't help me he won't
help me either but
he's really good at it and so he just
moved to the san diego
he live in beach lifestyle he's surfing
every day
yeah and writing poetry about it yeah
he's writing poe
and so he sends a poem but not only does
he send a poem he makes a video
and he performs the poem and he like
gets pictures
like you know and he sends it and then
for his grandma every week
and then everyone else has to you know
we're sitting there and we're listening
to his poem
even though he thinks the meeting is
boring well
he check he comes to the meeting for
like two minutes and then he just leaves
and then later he goes well this is
boring and he doesn't get that this is
for your grandma
this ain't for him you know what i mean
so yeah you guys probably
oh my god if he's like that and you're
the way you are
you guys well my older brother he
doesn't show up at all to those family
meetings but he's got like he's like ocd
like to the max though right or add or
whatever that is
we don't like to put titles
[Laughter]
the man can't sit still for a second
okay he cannot sit still for a second
he's just moving moving
he came over here he poked his head in
hey eric then
rachel showed him around and then he got
in his car and he left
that's just who he is yeah so you know
and so
with my mom just imagine my parents
dealing with little
people that are like that you know and
so
it was just kids running around
crazy and being selfish do you ever
you ever think that you do have you ever
thought well i should probably apologize
to from
to my mom for my behavior
as a teen yeah and i'm pretty sure i
have at one point
did you i meant to ask her probably when
i was
maybe like a couple years ago oh yeah
because you look back and like let's see
i wrecked how many cars
i got a dui yeah i got it
oh i did i did both of those and
you know my parents had to deal with a
lot with me
and i totally put them through it but i
think my brothers learned from my
mistakes
you know i was kind of the black sheep
of the family
i really yeah you know what i can
believe that
you have you have a your your guys your
family is very goody tissues you know
what's funny about
like you like with mike with michael
with her brother
her brother will rat on her in a second
too
he would drop a dime on rachel the
second tier like whatever she does
he was gonna call his mom be like mom
guess what rachel did
he's such a mama's boy your mom will
never admit that michael's her favorite
huh
um i mean both my brothers are
mama's boys and then i'm a total daddy's
girl so
yeah yeah you have a tattoo yeah do your
parents even know about that they have
to have seen this yeah of course when i
showed them the first time after i got
it your mom went to rehab
no you know like i was kind of like
you know i got a tattoo it says daddy's
girl
like because i love you
and then my dad was like you know that
it's an honor but
many ways to show me for yourself
because that's not how
um i'd want you to show it you know
and so you know what what are they going
to do after that
i'm surprised that some people when they
get tattoos it becomes addictive
and they start getting tattoos all over
that was like that's the only one you've
ever gotten like
why didn't you get other tattoos is that
just something that you just would like
i'm not really into it you know i think
i had like you know when i was probably
in high school
a lot of my friends um a lot of the
um guys who i was hanging out with
had tattoos and would like just go over
to each other's houses and tattoo each
other
and um are you hanging out with
like wow they were like beach kids
that you know they already knew that
they wanted to become like
tattoo artists so you know they would
just practice on each other
and um and so i'd watch
like for many years i'd like just watch
people get tattoos and
there was always this curiosity of like
why would you want
like you know a specific thing on your
body forever
um you know it was always kind of like a
curious
like question of mine of like why they
would do it so you know
wasn't modeling a part of it too that
you didn't want to well
i mean yeah you know it's like my body
you know i always learn to like treat it
as a temple
you know like you only have one body so
you know treat it well but
you know as an artist and as a model
you you hear that you want like a clean
slate a clean
canvas for you know whoever you're
working with
to work on or you know exact work with
and
so from that point it makes sense
not to have tattoos but i think
throughout the last
years at least the last decade um
tattoos are just
more normal normalized especially
through
social media and society and it's not
such a bad thing and i got this tattoo
when i was 21
i was starting i think in my head i was
like you know if i
ever get a tattoo i'd want it to be
purposeful and like something that means
a lot to me
and at that time i was studying
mechanical engineering
i thought i wanted to like
make motorcycles for the rest of my life
at that time
i was working at a motorcycle shop you
know and i was like
drawing designing motorcycles and i was
like you know what
i'm gonna come out with this company
called daddy's girl motorcycles oh wow
and i like it kind of like research how
to like
make a small business and like all these
steps
and like it was kind of just like
okay like this is gonna be real i'm
gonna make it
happen and it was kind of like the ink
on my skin
kind of like the start of the company
and so it was like kind of meaningful in
that way
but it was also well then what happened
like
how come you never did that you know
things happen
[Music]
i got you know i realized i didn't want
to work
out in a dirty car mechanic shop
i was always freezing cold you know you
in the summer it's
like hot in california you're sweating
in like these you know you have to wear
jeans you have to wear
stuff that covers your skin if you don't
want like
it to get burned or you know damaged
you realize you're two girly girls yeah
i re you know you don't realize it until
you actually
like put in the work and realize what it
takes
and after that point i was like you know
i don't think this is for me
everything i was like working towards i
kind of was like
you know maybe i need to switch paths
and so
at that point i
i was i think 22 20
or no i was probably like 24 25
and that's when i started you know
kind of i didn't know exactly what i
wanted to do but i was
out in l.a just like kind of hanging out
with
people models that were in the industry
working
and they were all like why don't you
model you know you're tall you're skinny
you're beautiful
and so i kind of just was like you know
what you're right maybe i should get in
to modeling again i did when i was
younger but then i got out of it during
college just because of school i
couldn't keep
up with it and so i i went back to la
models and they
they you know started
having me work and from there i kind of
just realized that
you know if i'm going to make it
modeling this is my time
as well to you know what you do you did
the best you could do it's just like the
modeling industry is just so different
now as opposed to like say how it was
before
i mean people have this perception that
like runway models oh man you want to be
a runway model
runway models don't make money unless
you're like kendall jenner
you already have a name and you're
already making money or something but
runway models it's just a dime a dozen
and they just get treated like
you know walking hangers is all they are
it's not like how it was
where it was you know back in the 80s
and 90s when it was like
models had a household name i mean it's
just so different now
you know right because it is i mean i
was
just watching the spring summer
2021 shows just now and when you watch
all the models walking down there's
probably like hundreds
and you're just like i'm happy that that
girl got that job
but like there's so many of them like
there's not enough jobs
for all of them to keep working so it's
it's just sad in that way of like
well they got to work but i didn't get
to work but if
you know yeah yeah yeah so it's just a
weird industry
right now and i remember going to but i
just remember going to that
one of your shows and just being like i
didn't get it i don't get high fashion
at all i know we've talked about this
before so we won't go into it again
but i mean it just is what it is i don't
know i'm enjoying being like i didn't
realize i would enjoy
so much you know being at home
all the time you know i didn't think you
would be
i didn't think so at home all the time
even on my days off i'm like
don't i get a day off
aren't you gonna go leave and get some
lunch at some point any day
i know and then we had this uh we had
this great like nest
camera at our front door so it just
always takes place so like when she
comes home
you know it goes rachel's here and
whatever and so she's always checking
like it goes you never left you never
leave
and i realize that i just don't i don't
know why i you know
for so many years now i was getting on
planes
you know three four five times a month
you know just flying all the time i
haven't been on a plane since march
of last year i haven't been on a plane i
you know i don't
you know i don't drive that you know
they say you get a discount on the
insurance if you drive
less than 50 miles a day i don't drive
50 miles in a week
maybe even in two weeks so i'm just at
home and i don't know i got
i guess i just i am enjoying it it feels
like if i
if i hit it big in the stock market like
like those people that i don't know just
whatever happened with gamestop i wish i
had all my money in that
or if i won the lottery or something
like that i'd tell you like hey let's
just go
live on it i really would be okay with
like just disappearing
well i would kind of be nervous because
where is the hospital
on this like okay obviously you know
what i mean it would be some place where
we could get to
like we don't remember immunity shots
yet
why you gotta ruin my dream can i have
my can i have my fantasy without you
bringing reality into it okay well i
don't know if that's my
fantasy dream what's your dream fantasy
then
um probably like somewhere in pacific
palisades
the cali girl to her core
like all these comics and people that
are leaving la going to texas and all
these places they always talk to me
about
man you should come to austin you should
move to here i'm like i ain't leaving
here i mean for a lot of reasons my
parents
live here my mom's got dementia so i got
to be near you know and rachel's whole
family's
everybody everybody lives here your
parents well i mean
yeah my i'm just saying you're immediate
you're going to immediately
does live in california in l.a but um
but finished his dream so we're going to
live in the palisades or where
yeah i was there today
i went to the new air one in the pacific
house
why do you like going to that fancy
store
i don't know why she likes going to like
rachel gotta she can't just go to the
grocery store
she can't go to the boxing it's like oh
my god it's kind of like
it's like the fresh produce organic
scene
it's like everyone's dressed up oh and
they're coveted attire
oh my gosh you have to have fancy cover
to tire and then you have to like
kind of act like you're keeping six
distance but you also need that apple
so like you're kind of like in line
[Laughter]
so it's a whole thing going inside
it's a lot of nonsense it's part of the
membership oh there's an air one
membership yeah
it's expensive so i always have to say
no but wait
why how much is it i want to be a member
yeah look it up i want to see what this
is all about so tell me more about
what you did today with the ir1 well my
brother
michael actually told me it was new
and to go check it out because i went to
the air one in
venice um and
they don't sell alcohol and so
during the new year i was looking for
like a nice wine
and so he told me that they had alcohol
there so
it's hundred dollars a month to be a
member no no an
annual membership of two hundred dollars
so that's like whatever that is
what's the benefit what do you get okay
so the air one member okay you get 10
off this is not an ad points i know it's
not enough i'm not getting i should get
some money for that they should give me
free membership for this okay
25 off monthly exclusive members only
brands
so you get 25 off you know this might
actually be worth it if you
exclusively shop there well i
exclusively buy fruit from there because
their fruit is really
good first access to air one member
merchandise whatever that means uh
all right membership details memberships
can be used at the air once
there was also well first i went to the
one in venice and there was a line out
the door
so i was like that's ridiculous i'm not
waiting in line in this freezing cold
60 degrees weather so i went to the
other one
okay so and it was like attached to this
like outdoor mall
type area and everyone was like outdoor
dining it was
really beautiful aren't you glad that
outdoor dining is back
yeah yeah we haven't gone to a
restaurant yet but i mean
like now that like you've or i've gone
through this covid protocol
of like keeping a distance wearing a
mask like
you know it going back to reality it's
weird it's like
yeah it's almost like it's like i almost
feel like people are disgusting when
they're
when they're not wearing their mask yeah
i know what you mean it's like we're
getting to a point like how can we go
back
yeah like i said but that's dirtier like
are you not gonna
use hand sanitizer anymore i know but
that makes me
nervous about you know
musicians and artists that need crowds
it makes me nervous about that like i
want to be able to
go to a concert again and be right next
to people and jumping and dancing and
whatever the people i mean
to be honest i i don't even think about
that because i'm such a home buddy that
like
i'm enjoying just being at home with you
on my days off and going to the grocery
store
the best thing ever happened to our
relationship
i don't know that's it like that's what
i like to do
and i don't really like going to crowds
i kind of do have a nice routine like i
i enjoy it
a little anti-social yeah i know i think
we're both a little anti-social now it's
like i have to remind her that she has
friends and to hit him up
but even when you don't i'm just like
well we got it you know like i got you i
got you
baby i got you babe you're her uncle
aaron always says we're the new
sunny and cheer and i actually like
looked up on youtube
like all their old episodes it's so cute
yeah they used to do that a lot on uh
when i was a kid i highly recommend
everyone going to look at their sunday
and share like that should be a thing
i didn't even know that that existed oh
there was a lot of them back in the day
there was a lot of like variety shows
and people
they sang songs i would love to do that
with you
stage and everything oh my god can you
are you gonna you gonna sing
i mean well
i could hold a mic and like sway
[Laughter]
and we'll have like a fake singer in the
back like we'll
i'll hire like christina aguilera to be
your i would love christina aguilera to
be my
voice or britney spears i watch her
dance videos all the time thinking i'm
gonna
just start doing that too
[Laughter]
i hope not please don't i don't know but
um
anyways you know this is uh i love when
you come on people ask about you by the
way
but rachel's gonna start her own thing
we're gonna i'm gonna help her start her
own thing
i hate my boyfriend's couch because she
literally does then she'll have her
friend come over or someone and
they'll sit on the couch and i'll tape
them there and then they'll just talk
about the things they hate about their
boyfriend
and then get into other subjects i just
don't want you to start talking like all
those
other rachel listens to so many
female podcasts well i'm really into sex
and relationship
advice from people who aren't qualified
oh i got shots fired no but they all for
some reason
for some reason all the girls they talk
like this
and then i was going out and oh my god
why do they all talk like this rachel
why i understand perfectly what do you
explain it to me it's like a cadence
yeah i know it's a cadence it's an
annoying cadence
why do they all talk like that i don't
know if you start talking like that
we're done
i really don't really know what you're
talking about because i feel like i
already do that
no you're not not to the point that they
do it okay yeah it's like really
annoying
but she listens to all of them i
actually know and then she listens to
sex with emily all the time i know emily
i've been on her radio show a couple of
times and i've almost called in a few
times i almost have to tell her like you
need to chill
because
because rachel will come in the door and
be like i heard on sex with emily that
we need to do
this and i'm like oh no so shout out to
emily sex with emily
it's like she's actually really she's a
i think she's a licensed sex
sexologist or whatever you would call it
but i need to i want a doctor
yeah doctor sex doctor i want to have
her come on i'm gonna have her come on
and then you know you'll talk we can
like talk to her together
about our sex life she like talks to
people with like problems and questions
do we have problems
no okay so we'll just be typical advice
okay we could ask for fun tips
i did like take her advice on like lube
choices that she always talks about and
i hate them i
literally hate you you don't like that
lou no i like it
[Laughter]
i like that it's it's a it's a good
feeling so now i kind of like
i'm a little hesitant on her reviews
yeah yeah you know what's weird maybe
you should get some different
lubes okay so if you're a lube company
out there send some lube to rachel's
so she can like pump it up for her
that'd be your first sponsor it'll be
like a lube sponsor huh
well i just i don't like coconut oil
you're the one that got it what do you
talk about you love that
i massage you with that one coconut oil
yeah i like it with
for a massage but not in my body oh okay
all right anyway that's
this is the part that's a weird this is
your part with whether your family
listens
it's gonna be like ah okay i want to
know about this part
so your dad sorry ken turn this off
right now
sorry that you have that visual we
didn't even use it because i hated
[Laughter]
okay well i'm just kidding all right uh
but anyways so look out for that and uh
you know and then my youtube page
oh here we go so pump okay rachel please
pump all of your
uh where can people find you rachel
um i still don't really know what the
link is
you know what i'll put the link down
below she's only got two videos up there
anyway
the problem i only have one video oh you
took the other one down yeah oh the
problem is is there
there's an author with the same name so
when you looked it up
she's the more famous rachel sklar so
that's but we're going to change that as
we can soon i'll be rachel griffin
is there another rachel griffin i don't
think so well good
rachel griffin you like that rg i like i
like my initials as eg
and you'll be rgg oh that was cute
that's so adorable all right guys um
make sure you check me out on twitch
daily era griffin gaming
on twitch i put a lot of videos on
youtube but mostly i'm on twitch so make
sure you check out twitch
i was i was streaming on youtube also
but i think that the contract with the
twitch partner when you're a twitch
partner
i don't think you're allowed to actually
game on another platform
even if you're like i thought it was
just simultaneously you couldn't do it
at the same time
but apparently so i haven't done it in a
while because i'm not sure i got
and it's like all this legalese on the
on the partnership thing so i don't know
so make sure you check me out there
i'll have all i'll have rachel's links
below and look out for her thing and you
know she'll be on sporadically here and
there and i love having her on i love
having this beautiful lady in my life i
have not officially
like you know proposed and all that
stuff yet but i will trust me
because every time she reminds me of it
i know i have to push it back because
that means she's going to be looking out
for it oh do we want to talk about
valentine's day yet
no i don't think we want to talk about
valentine's day yet rachel she's
she's got like all set up in the other
room of like her valentine's day episode
so
she made another video which are you
gonna put that one out your valentine's
day pre-valentine's day video
yeah it's gonna be a pre-valentine's day
video so
everyone could watch it to get ready for
valentine's day and get ideas of what
they should do for their couples or
their partners or their gals all right
so look out for that you know what i
might do is i might actually put that
video
up on my channel with links to her
channel that will build up her channel
you know i don't know my channel isn't
even built up but for our loyal fans
that we have here for the few thousand
people that like coming to watch
mcgriffin and the p the non-haters of
rachel and our relationship
you know guys you know come and let's
support this is what we're doing we're
making content
and the more content we can make the
more rachel and i can spend time
together and i don't have to go on the
road and do
do that i can just stay here with her so
then i don't have to go
to my second job yeah her second job the
job but yeah but we
there's a lot of benefits to that your
job
you know but anyways thanks for watching
we're from with griffin
this is rachel sklar the beautiful
rachel sklar
and this is eric griffin and i will see
you guys
next week see you later
you